-The president mounted
an appallingly racist attack
on four Democratic women
of color in Congress.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's been obvious from
the very first moment he stepped
onto the political stage
that Donald Trump is a racist,
and that racism is at the core
of his political ideology.
It's not a side dish.
It's the main course.
Every day, he serves up
a steaming hot entree of racism
and then washes it down
with a side of...
-McDonald's, Wendy's,
and Burger King for some pizza.
[ Laughter, cheers ]
-Trump launched
his political career
by questioning legitimacy
of the first black president,
began his campaign by claiming
Mexico is sending criminals
and rapists to the U.S.,
and said a judge who
was overseeing a lawsuit
against him in 2016
shouldn't be allowed
to oversee the case
because of his ethnicity.
-Now, this judge
is of Mexican heritage.
I'm building a wall, okay?
I'm building a wall.
-But you're invoking his race
when talking about
whether or not
he can do his job.
-Jake, I'm building a wall.
Okay?
I'm building a wall.
-If you are saying he can't
do his job because of his race,
is that not
the definition of racism?
-No, I don't think so at all.
-No?
-No. He's proud of his heritage.
I respect him for that.
-You're saying he can't do
his job because of that.
-Look, he's proud
of his heritage, okay?
I'm building a wall.
This judge is giving us
unfair rulings.
Now I say, why?
Well, I'm building a wall.
-Okay, but why won't you
tell us what you're building?
[ Laughter ]
He keeps saying it over and over
like he's wearing a wire
and calling for backup.
"I'm building a wall.
I'm building a wall.
Wall!
Steve, get me out of here!"
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump launched
a racist attack on a judge
by calling him unqualified
to rule in a case
because of their ethnicity,
and, by the way,
in case you're somehow
still curious about
Donald Trump's legal bona fides,
here's what he had
to say on Friday about
Special Counsel Robert Mueller's
report which listed
10 possible instances
of obstruction of justice.
Remember, 10. 10!
Somehow, everyone's
forgotten about that,
because it was like
50 scandals ago.
We all have such scandal
fatigue,
at this point,
Trump could streak naked
across the White House lawn
with his head stuck
in a KFC bucket,
screaming, "I did it.
I broke all the laws,"
and two days later,
we'll all be scratching
our heads, going,
"Oh, yeah, right.
That happened."
So, Trump was asked about
the Mueller report on Friday,
and he tried to claim that
Article 2 of the Constitution
gives him the power to,
basically, do whatever he wants.
Now, remember,
this is the same guy
who said a judge wasn't
qualified to rule on a case
because of
that judge's ethnicity.
By comparison,
here's Trump talking about
Article 2 of the Constitution
of the United States.
-Number one, there's no crime.
And how do you obstruct
when there's no crime?
Also, take a look
at one other thing.
It's a thing called Article 2.
Nobody ever mentions Article 2.
It gives me all of these rights
at a level that nobody
has ever seen before.
We don't even talk
about Article 2.
-what do you mean,
nobody has ever seen before?
It was written
over 200 years ago.
just because you've
never seen it before
doesn't mean
nobody's ever seen it before.
"I just saw this great
little independent film.
No one's ever seen it before,
called 'The Lion King.'"
[ Laughter ]
it's about a good
guy named Scar,
but oh, he's got
a real a [bleep] nephew
who tries to backstab him.
[ Laughter ]
But I like Scar --
I haven't finished it.
It's two hours long.
That's too long.
But I like Scar's chances.
I think --
I think it's gonna end well
for Scar."
Also his interpretation of
Article 2 is obviously wrong,
which is not surprising
since he, apparently,
just discovered it.
"Here's another thing
I just learned.
Did you know we had a president
who was 100 feet tall?
[ Light laughter ]
Made of stone."
What we saw in that interview
was the core of Trump's
racist world view,
and we saw yet again on Sunday
when Trump launched
a stunningly racist attack
On four progressive women
of color in Congress.
-The President
of the United States
told progressive Democratic
women of color in Congress
to go back to the crime-infested
places from which they came.
Trump writing this --
"So interesting to see
progressive
Democrat Congresswomen
who originally
came from countries
Whose governments are a complete
and total catastrophe,
The worst, most corrupt,
and inept anywhere in the world,
If they even have
a functioning government at all,
now loudly and viciously
telling the people
of the United States,
the greatest and most powerful
nation on Earth,
how our government is to be run.
Why don't they go back
and help fix
the totally broken
and crime-infested places
from which they came?
Then come back
and show us how it is done.
These places
need your help badly.
You can't leave fast enough.
I'm sure that Nancy Pelosi
would be very happy
to quickly work out
free travel arrangements."
-Okay, first of all,
there's no acceptable word
for this other than racist,
period.
Not racially charged
or racially tinged or,
as "The New York Times" put it,
Trump's racially-
infused politics,
like it's some kind
of fancy drink
At a Williamsburg cocktail bar.
"Oh, honey, their cosmo
is racially infused."
Second,
this is beside the point,
but three of the Congresswomen
you're attacking were born here,
and they're all
American citizens.
So, if you're asking them to fix
the totally broken
crime-infested governments
of their home countries,
they're trying.
[ Laughter, cheering ]
It doesn't matter...
Doesn't matter whether
they were born here or not,
they're Americans.
This is their country,
and they are treating it
with a lot more
respect and devotion
than the racist gargoyle
who sits around,
tweeting from the back nine
of his chintzy golf course.
I mean, look at that.
That looks like a sculpture
someone would build
to make fun of Donald Trump.
I call this one
"The Melting Racist."
And then today
Trump reeled off
yet another racist tirade
at a White House event called
the "Made in America"
product showcase.
First, he took questions
from reporters
and defended his tweet
when asked if they were racist.
-Not at all.
-Democratic Congresswomen
are not American?
-Somebody has a problem
with our country,
if somebody doesn't want
to be in our country,
they should leave.
-I think it's very fitting
that he's standing
next to a boat
because he always looks
like he just fell off
the side of a booze cruise
and got dragged back onto deck
by a lifeguard.
Then Trump moved
over to the podium
where he continued his tirade
and doubled down
on those racist tweets.
-If you're not happy
in the U.S.,
if you're complaining
all the time,
very simply, you can leave.
You can leave right now.
Come back if you want.
Don't come back.
It's okay, too.
But if you're not happy,
you can leave.
-I'm sorry, you're accusing
someone else of comp--
All you do is complain.
You spent the eight years
of Obama's presidency
lying and complaining
about everything.
In fact, at one point,
you actually bragged
about the fact that
you were great at whining.
-I am the most fabulous whiner.
I do whine because
I want to win.
And I'm not hap--
-Are whiners winners?
-And I am a whiner,
and I'm a whiner,
and I keep whining and whining
until I win.
-That is a terrible
Dr. Seuss book.
"I keep whining and whining
until I'm a winner.
And then I go home
and have pizza for dinner."
[ Laughter ]
Trump's attack on four
progressive women of color
wasn't just blatantly
and appallingly racist,
it's also a classic
racist trope.
It's the kind of taunt
and insult people of color
have been
subjected to for years,
as Senator Kamala Harris
explained.
-It's absolutely racist
and un-American,
and it is an old trope --
"Go back to where
you came from."
You might hear it on the street,
but should never hear that
from the President
of the United States.
-And she's right.
Trump shouldn't be president.
At best, he should
be on the street
selling fake Rolexes
in Times Square
and yelling at tourists
for not buying them.
"Oh, what?!
You never heard of a Polex?"
[ Laughter ]
What we're seeing now,
once again,
is the core of Trump's racist
ideology and policy agenda.
His administration is
inflicting cruelty on migrants
through inhumane
detention centers,
family separation,
and he spent his career
questioning the legitimacy
of everyone
from the first black president
to judges
to members of Congress.
What more do you need
to impeach this guy?
Congress should
just say to him...
-You can leave.
You can leave right now.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]